but in the The Talk of the Town is the
main event Tom aspinall if you gave me a
hundred thousand dollars and I could bet
on one fighter that I can guarantee he's
gonna be a world champion Tom aspinal I
think the way if you look at the lay of
the land what Tom did to Tiberia I mean
he was a big favorite for a reason but
after that layoff that bad injury with
the knee he's going through some issues
it sounds like his personal life with
his camp and outside of the gym I knew
he'd beat him but not like this I mean
it was even competitive I think he beats
Pavlich I think if he can just avoid him
that first round he dragged Pavlich into
second third fourth round he beats him
but I just you look at the matchups take
Jon Jones out of it I don't see anybody
beating Tom aspinal he's too damn good
big boy two six five the kid's a problem
black belt on the ground great hands
confidence swaggers there you give me
100 Grand a bet on one UFC fighter
become Champion the next year it's Tom
aspinal